- Almost that time again.
Piece one, piece two
with my trusty outfit.
I turn into
airport Gary.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
Dude.
- Good to see you.
Heard you got in last night.
- Yeah, late.
How are you?
- Good, man.
- It's good to see you, man.
- You as well.
- You going out now?
- I'm going out just before you.
I'll warm them up for you.
- Thank you.
- I'll break it up.
I'll get it
smoothed out, you know.
- [Gary] Yeah, meet a
really good friend of mine, Boz.
- [DRock] Hi, how are you?
- [Boz] Boz.
- [Man] Gary, I don't
want to disturb you.
I'm a big fan of yours.
Can I take a picture of you?
- [Gary] Sure. Of course.
- Thank you so much.
- One most important
step in the beginning.
Okay, we jumped from
being a small entrepreneur.
- It was always selling.
It was always
getting new clients.
It was my ability
to sell new clients
as we learned
how to do what
we were going to do.
- Right.
- If your ability to
outsell yourself is there,
you always have a business.
- And the most important
thing is to keep going.
Not just to start, right?
- Course, that's the game.
- That's the game.
- It's pattern recognition.
AI, voice, VR,
we're gonna see it three,
four, five more times.
- [Boz] 9 times out of
10 the guy who doesn't bolt,
he's fine. There's
no tiger in the bush.
- Right.
- [Boz] But 1 time out of 10
there's a tiger in the bush.
We're the decedents
of the one who ran.
- It's true.
- [Boz] We got these patterns.
- That's true. I like that.
- [Boz] You can
get really far ahead.
- 100%. By the way, if I hadn't
lived through early Web 1.0,
Web 2.0, the social
media thing, my statement
about VR consumer,--
- [Boz] Totally wouldn't play.
- I wouldn't have
said 10 or 20 years.
I would have said
next couple years.
- [Boz] Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Totally.
- You learn that
it takes a little bit
longer than you think.
- [Boz] Yeah.
- When it's that big of a shift.
- [Boz] Totally.
- [Woman] I'm just
gonna record out what you're
saying with my iPhone.
- Do you want me to hold it?
- [Woman] Yeah,
that'd be really cool.
- Yeah, sure.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Full service,
I'm full service.
Give interviews, record.
- [Woman] That's cool. Okay.
How do you manage to
create all of this content?
- [Gary] Well it's really great
when you have DRock around.
For everybody who
doesn't see, I've got DRock,
David Rock, who films me.
I have a full team now.
I used to just
put in a lot of hours.
When Twitter came
out in 2006 I spent 12,
13 hours a day
replying to people.
I put in the work.
You know this.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- You're not accomplishing
what you're accomplishing
without the work.
That's it.
You sleep less.
You watch less TV, you
play less games on your phone.
You create. You work.
But it's patience.
The biggest thing that I'm
scared of for the people that
are watching right now is
they do it for three months,
they do it for six
months and they give up.
I did Wine Library TV my first
thing on YouTube for 18 months,
every single day
and nobody was watching.
But I knew it was right.
And so, if I could give any
advice from an old man here,
it's patience which is
very hard when you're 13,
16, 19, 22, 27
because you want it so bad.
But patience is the game.
DRock, when do you
think "The Manifesto"?
You see people are
starting to pick up it 'cause
it was in that episode.
- [DRock] Yeah, I saw.
- I mean we
really, really, really,
let's really drill it.
Yes?
- [Tina] Hi. Tina.
- Hi Tina.
- [Tina] I just
wanted to make a photo.
- Sure. It's okay,
I can do it. Yeah, of course.
- We just want to do one
more thing and then we're--
- Yeah, no worries.
You know getting to travel all
around the world it just really
fascinating to me that the
Online Rock Stars event here in
Hamburg, Germany has become
one of the premier events.
It comes down to
people need permission.
- [Man 2] Yes!
- [Gary] It's not,
it's not about...
People aren't
confused with the answers.
I've given the
answers 50,000 times.
- [Man 2] You're not bored
with the same answers.
- [Gary] No, because
I know every single time
this is going to be the time one
person hears it when they needed
to and they'll do.
To me, it's the mission
of getting people to do not,
you know, I don't get bored.
The platforms change.
It used to be like
make a MySpace page,
be a blogger, right?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- So the platforms change so
that keeps it fresh but the
thesis stays the same.
I am stunned by the lack of
practitioner-ship in our space.
WHW, right?
What are you gonna talk about?
So many of you in
this room have not started.
Whether you're talking
about yourself or your product,
you have not
started the process.
Now the reality is so many of
you are at such an early stage
that manifesto should
actually just be your mission.
Right, you haven't
done anything yet.
This whole fake it 'til you make
it brings no value to anybody.
You need to tell me what you're
gonna do which is very scary
'cause you actually
have to execute on it.
Another part that so many of
you need to think about is how.
Facebook video, YouTube crushing
it but there're so many people
in here that shouldn't be
producing video because that is
not the best way
they communicate.
Actually start understanding
how this is all working,
deeper not wider.
I leave the future to the people
that are building the future.
What I'm good at is tasting
the future very quickly and
executing within it.
I think the biggest thing
that holds people back is fear.
Fear of what other people think.
I just want to look back and
feel proud about what I said.
- [Man 3] Okay,
thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- I got to go.
- [Man 4] You changed my life!
- Thank you, brother.
Thank you guys.
I got to go.
I'm sorry.
("Rooftops" by Cabbie)
Hard work is not fun.
It doesn't come
natural to a lot of people.
We always had
people that talked.
people that were lazy.
We always had people
that complained and so,
yes, I think that's
human nature because it's
very difficult to be successful.
Yeah, I mean
that's always been media.
Now, it's a bunch of people
throwing up Lamborghinis and
watches on Instagram.
It used to be "Lifestyles
of the Rich and Famous"
and informercials.
Again, nothing's changed.
People do the same things.
The mediums have changed, the
behaviors have stayed the same.
- You build VaynerMedia
into an international
agency in six years, right?
So what has been the best
decision you've made so far?
- Phew, that's a good question.
I think the best
decision I made was to
not waver from the strategy.
When I started selling social
media in 2009 and '10 to the
biggest companies in the
world they didn't want it.
So, I think the best decision
I made was to be very focused.
To not listen to the majority
of people and to believe in my
intuition that it would become
as important as it became.
I mean so many of them are
building companies that they're
thinking I'm gonna
raise more money and
I'm gonna build this big thing.
They're gonna get caught.
Making money's
always a good idea.
You're not a hero by
losing money every month.
Think that they're wrong but
I think that
they're right for them.
I've lost tens of thousands
of followers through the years
'cause I've put out too much
content but I've picked up
millions in return.
- Rotation, right?
- That's right. The end.
- Okay.
- Now, there's another thing.
There is too much content
if you're not good enough.
- But numbers are
saying that we're growing.
- I'd rather look
at the numbers than
your friend Pedro's opinion.
- Okay. Okay.
- [Gary] I don't
care about the questions,
I care about the actions.
Why I like you two
is you're doing things.
I'm saying things
and you're doing.
Don't listen to what I'm
saying, watch what I'm doing.
- [Man 5] Straight
to the airport?
- Yes, please.
Got some WHW in, right?
- [DRock] Yep. WHW.
- [Gary] We just show
peoples, five faces in
four seconds of
speaking to camera.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Got it?
- [DRock] I got that.
- (stammers)
I'm sorry. Where, what,
how we show podcasts, blogs.
'Cause I actually
want you to win.
Adrian said,
somebody said,
"GaryVee, would
you follow yourself
if you weren't
yourself?" I said no.
Adrian said, "Exactly, the more
I learn from you the less I give
"a shit about you.
I love it. True coaching.
"Stepping up my own game."
One day a lot of you
will realize it's 'cause I,
and geez, I'm looking
and I'm paying attention.
I'm in the minority of this
because they're very few people
building substantial
business wealth,
selfish things,
outside their success of their
personal brand at this level.
You're gonna realize one day the
difference between me and the
far majority of the other people
you're giving attention to is
I actually want you to win.
Not I want to make it feel
like I want you to win but
I actually want to win.
Pay attention not to what
people say but what they do.
Punchline for me
is here's what I do,
just really expect
nothing from you.
Will give you everything.
Sure, occasionally a book.
Occasionally a sweater.
But could care less if
you buy any of those things.
I just ask.
That shit pisses me off.
I get all up in you, you
actually stop watching me and
then you go watch fucking
dumb fuckers that have
half the fuckin' value and
an eighth of the value.
So you feel good 'cause you
unfollow DailyVee or me on
Instagram and then
you're going to watch hucksters.
Fuckin' stupid.
Doing means doing.
Doing doesn't mean stop watching
me and that's the tactic that
makes you feel good.
- [DRock] It's not like you
want them to unfollow you.
It's you want them
to unfollow everybody.
- I want them to
unfollow everybody.
By the way, I watch the Jets.
It's not that I want
them to unfollow me,
it's just I want
them to do more.
More, more, more.
That Drake thing was crazy.
- [DRock] That was crazy.
- And we'll never really
know but it's way too random.
Drizzy.
(DRock laughs)
Drizzy!
And is the other
business making money?
- Yeah.
- And the car
thing's your passion.
- Yeah, yeah. It's true.
- I get it. It's classic.
You got to do both.
- Yeah, I tried to.
I would try--
- But it's taking
up too much time?
Yeah, 80/20. And?
- A lot of stuff
I'm doing the filming,
editing stuff
and so little time.
- I would try to get an
intern then to help you with
some of the stuff.
- Yeah, okay.
- And even though
you're not big yet,
you'd be surprised.
You live here?
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's 5,000 kids in Hamburg
that are 15 years old that are
more talented than you editing.
- Yeah.
- That will just think it's
cool to edit your YouTube.
- Okay, I got it.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'd go to Twitter,
I'd go to YouTube,
I'd go to Instagram and
I'd reach out to people.
- Okay.
- You're next
video on YouTube,--
- Yeah.
- make a video that says, hey,
I need a full-time editor intern
but I'm gonna make it one
day and I'll pay you back.
- Okay.
- And one person
has to believe you.
- Got it. Okay.
- Not bad, right?
- Yeah, it's a really good idea.
- You know what happens?
People are scared to have
somebody work for them for free
'cause they're good people.
- Yeah.
- I'm scared.
I didn't say yes
to DRock at first.
I'm scared.
- Yeah.
- But if I'm gonna do something,
I know it's going to be
successful and the best thing
that ever happened to DRock was
he made a film or
two for me for free.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Best thing. 100%.
- Yeah.
- Best fucking thing, dick.
(group laughter)
So, you know, that's it.
So let me give you an example.
If a 15-year-old edits
for you for two years and
you don't make it.
- Yeah.
- Well then you pay him.
- Yeah, okay.
- One day.
- One day, yeah.
- People don't understand,
life's about trading and
there's a lot of ways to trade.
- Yeah.
- That 15-year-old will
get a lot of experience.
It's your phone.
That's your alarm to
make sure you don't miss me.
(DRock laughs)
Yeah, we're sorry.
We're busy here.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Awesome, man.
Take care of yourself. Yeah.
Take care, my friend.
- [Man 6] Thank you.
- Stay well.
- [Man 6] Take care.
- Take care.
- And you do an
awesome job. I really love it.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
Almost that time again.
That time the kids love so much.
Piece one,
where's the second piece?
It's in here somewhere.
Piece two.
Hey kids, it's almost time for
airport Gary
with my trusty outfit.
- [DRock] We really need
some super hero music.
- (laughs) Do it!
I turn into
airport Gary.
(DRock chuckles)
Hamburg, thank you so much.
Great event.
A lot of good content today.
("Focus" by K.A.A.N)
The themes are
simple, my friends.
You're gonna get
bored of it eventually.
More, more, more.
Do, do, do.
It's the actions.
Fucking the actions.
I want it so bad for you.
I want it so bad
'cause I'm selfish.
Because I want that feeling of
people coming up to me and I can
see it in their fucking eye that
I'm making your life better.
You know how
fucking insane that is?
Thank you for the ones that
are doing and the ones that are
putting more time and effort.
You're making two
people very happy.
You and your world
and me and my world.
You only get to
live this life one time.
Once.
You only get to do it one time.
And one very smart thing a lot
of you youngsters can do is go
volunteer at a nursing home one
time and go hang out with people
that are 70, 80, 90.
Like your grandparents,
like your great-grandparents.
The number one thing they'll
tell you is they regret the
things they didn't do. So try.
What are you waiting for?
Just 'cause somebody's gonna
make fun of you on your YouTube
video, you're not
gonna care in three,
four, five, six years but what
you might've left on the table
was the thing that
would've changed your life.
("Focus" by K.A.A.N)